У центрі великого індустріального міста
знаходиться національний заповідник.
2400 га, що в вісім разів більше,
ніж центральний парк у місті Нью-Йорк.
Я пишаюся цією «гігантоманією», звичайно.
Але для мене це ще й великий відпочинок.
Я підіймаюся на цей курган,
і я завжди радію цим краєвидам.
Я йду на роботу через міст, я збиваю піт.
Але мені подобається заходити на Хортицю,
коли співають солов'ї навесні.
Це моя любов.
Про Хортицю ви знаєте лише
завдяки Дніпровим порогам.
Від нашого міста до міста Дніпра
на 70 км йшли Дніпрові пороги.
Їх було дев'ять.
І ми вважаємо, що саме тут ходив Тарас Шевченко.
Що саме тут, дивлячись на останній порог,
він занотує собі у щоденнику деякі вірші.
Наприклад, такі:
«Було видно, було чути, як реве Ревучий».
А Ревучий реве тільки у Дніпрових порогах,
які зараз вже під товщею води.
Гребля ДніпроГЕС була побудована
в 1932 році, за п'ять років.
Вона підняла рівень води на 38,5 метрів
і затопила пороги.
Київ, Дніпро і Запоріжжя — це морські порти
лише завдяки греблі ДніпроГЕС.
А раніше піднятися порогами було неможливо.
Серед них є і місце загибелі Святослава Хороброго.
Це київський князь.
Він був справжнім лицарем і багато ходив у походи.
І на Волгу, і на Кавказ, і на Візантію.
І коли він повертався з Візантії,
з Балкан, якщо точніше,
в 972 році він загинув в цьому місці.
А в 2011 році рибалка випадково витягує меч.
Довжиною він 94 см,
руків'я оздоблено сріблом і латунню,
а на його лезі легендарне тавро: Ульфберт.
Такий меч — це Rolls-Royce тих часів.
Січі на острові Хортиця не було.
Як науковець я скажу,
що перша Запорізька Січ
була на острові Мала Хортиця.
У Старому Дніпрі є невеличкий острів Байда.
Саме там у 1552 році була побудована
Запорізька Січ Дмитром Байдою-Вишневецьким.
Ми представили основні споруди, які були.
Звичайно, має бути 38 куренів,
біля кожного куреня має бути курінна скарбничка,
але на всю Хортицю не розкинешся.
Кошовий отоман (ось його будинок), —
це голова усього Війська Запорозького Низового.
Січ — то лише столиця.
Багато хто плутає, що, мовляв,
всі козаки жили на Січі.
Це не так, тут жили десь 3-5 тисяч козаків.
А ось по паланках — це широченні землі
від Південного Бугу на заході
до Кальміусу й Дону на сході —  жило
до 40 тисяч козаків в селах, містечках, зимівниках.
На Січ жінок не пускають — це правда.
Все дуже просто: на Покров в Україні ярмарок.
Це не просто базар, як нам здається, а велика подія.
На кілька днів на цей ярмарок
з'їжджається вся людяність.
І матусі виводять своїх доньок на оглядини.
Козак це знає, користується і обирає найкращу.
І за пороги повертається з молодою дружиною,
живе, добра наживає, діточок плодить
та й горя не знає.
А зимівник — це його козацький хутір.
Це його фермерське господарство,
давайте казати по-сучасному.
Там він живе з родиною
і на нього працюють батраки.
Вони дуже непогано заробляють.
Пушкарня — арсенал запорожців.
Це зрубна будівля,
дах якої вкритий гонтою,
тобто дерев'яною черепичкою,
і тут до сотні гармат.
Дуже козацтво мені нагадував Майдан.
Самоорганізація там була січова.
Це було дуже подібне до козацтва.
У першу відправку з Запоріжжя
я одразу пішов в військомат.
Був рік на війні, з березня 2014-го
до березня 2015-го [року].
Це і Південий котел звільняли, і Красний Лиман,
і рейд за Маріуполь, і аеропорт Донецький двічі.
Перше поранення під аеропортом.
Потім Дебальцеве,
а точніше Логвінове під Дебальцеве.
Там було друге поранення.
Потім шпиталь і демобілізація.
Шабля була найсакральнішою зброєю
для запорозького козака.
Вони називали її «ненька-рідненька»
або «шаблюка-сестриця».
Навіть казали, що ні шаблю, ні жінку,
козак ніколи й нікому в інші руки не дава.
Зараз наші джури...
До речі, малята, ви знаєте, хто такі джури?
Ні!
Малята, джури — це маленькі хлопчики
або юнаки, що приходили на Січ до козаків.
Найчастіше це були сироти.
Вони тренувалися, навчалися,
а під час походу та бойових дій
вони допомагали козакам.
Саме так молодь переймала бойовий досвід.
Зараз наші джури покажуть вам,
як треба працювати такими шаблями.
— Готові?
— Так!
Поїхали!
Ось це захист.
Підійти до нього як спереду,
так і ззаду зараз важкувато.
Таким чином намагалися навіть стріли вібдивати.
А ось це напад.
Перевага двох шабель над однією —
вдвічі більше ударів наноситься.
Добре.
[оплески дітей]
Це мій друже.
Хортиця, я його прозвав Хорт.
То мій позивний такий.
По-козацьки прізвисько.
Це Гром.
Палій і Гром.
Це найкращий джигітовщик.
Він ще з дитинства з кіньми має справу.
Після школи одразу на коня сів,
і отам під брюхом, різні трюки.
Під брюхом було страшнувато [сміється].
Отримував пару разів копитом, ну нічо.
Так досвід приймаєш.
Щоб стати козаком, не обов'язково показати силу,
не обов'язково показати кремезність.
Це чудово: ти велетень.
Але якщо ти боягуз,
то ти нікому не потрібен.
Як приймали до козаків?
Перекидали дубову колоду через січові ворота.
Хто бажав стати козаком,
мав перейти через неї з зав'язаними очима.
Якщо кажеш: ні, хлопці, там скеля!
То ти свинопас, йди до пана.
Козак піде. Він йде з зав'язаними очима,
він підслизається, падає головою вниз,
а його в ряднину ловлять,
бо вони не душегуби все ж таки.
Тоді він буде козаком.
Козак — це відчайдушна людина,
яка здатна на вчинок.
Це не обов'язково велетень,
не обов'язково у нього має бути біцепс.
Це хоробра людина, передусім.
І от зараз наше завдання майбутнє покоління
не виховати манкуртами,
а виховати справжню нам зміну.
Саме тому ми працюємо у школах,
бо заповідник не тільки тут, він експансію робить.
Ми зробили семінари для всіх вчителів історії.
Ми показуємо фільми у школах.
Ми їздимо на Херсонщину.
Для того, щоб виховувати нове покоління.